[ __ ]
okay hello everyone welcome to another
welcome language design review meeting
part of our incremental language design
series
and we have a variety of topics first as
highlight text
okay uh
yeah those are those are the other
design proposal but I would support by
the left page which contains examples of
the function and the normal examples
there's like extras
I have to go to toffee tools to the web
page right you can click
the C ref highlight text link
no
is it highlighted
highlight highlight text
it's uh
maybe you should have just clicked on
the link well yeah right
except that yeah right it then says
highlight string there so I'm confused
okay
so this is an initial implementation of
some uh something that we were just
using for for
highlighting in NLP functions uh it's
basically plugs a hole in the language
we don't have anywhere Twilight I think
it's a good thing to have text there
that is not so clear at the design
so
right now what this is doing it supports
uh spans or or string patterns and it
supports uh labels
okay the text structure function this
should interoperate properly with the
text structure function
the thing it eats okay so several
comments okay good thing
the thing it eats should also be a
styled string should also be able to be
a text wrapper thing for example like
like for example if I say text of quotes
hello there
right
um
that should be highlightable as well see
what I'm saying yeah okay
um similarly you know if there's a style
wrapper
around the string it should be
highlightable
okay yeah I mean just be transparent to
some things that's that's not a big deal
yeah maybe not so implementation is
trivial
uh I'll check I mean tech text is
due to putting I mean taxes like inset
so it will just uh it uh whatever you
give uh I have to check what the result
of interaction with style so like yes
I'm also not so sure that it should
interact with style I mean I think you
should wrap the style on the outside I'm
not sure what it means to highlight text
when there's a style on the inside
well okay so one of the issues is
if your text already has a yellow
background and then you highlight with
yellow your toast whereas it could have
some sensible logic if it can see the
style it can have sensible Logic for
highlighting something that isn't just
you know you know dropped and you know
just sort of submerging oh if that is
what you want to do that's dangerous
because you know you might have
arbitrary nested things and we will need
to resolve basically obviously we've got
to resolve them to know how we you know
how we um
you know obviously they resolve in order
to tell how we actually render the thing
when we actually render the string yeah
because there's there's I mean the
examples on the right are all no
overlaps and no hierarchical stuff but
any part of the proposals that there
could be
you know but this is this is this is the
this is intersection that we control
what I'm saying is that we will have
basically to duplicate uh uh style
parsing that the front-end is doing to
realize what the actual theme to be
displayed will be and do something with
that okay I think we need for my
personal experience no I will explore it
but from I'm just telling you know from
my personal experience with stuff like
workload it's uh it's nothing it's not
trivial right so but let's look at the
left hand side first okay so this you
know
this stuff I'm I'm good with I think
this is nice and wait wait wait wait no
I I have I have things like this is nice
but okay there are a few things here
that I have to tell you so first what is
this this thing is not uh like a
arbitrary expression this is a new head
which right now I call annotated the
text or another string I don't remember
what was in the code and it basically is
an object that contains as a first
argument the string and as a second
argument the highlighting specification
it only typesets as this this way we can
keep the expression kernel
implementation as you know the string
will stay a string it doesn't get
destroyed right in fact it has
annotation let me understand how this
relates to like why that why why does
highlight text evaluate why doesn't it
just
types it then
well because it it needs to to you might
might want to do things like if you do
that and cache the results
yeah then you might want to do things
resolve these overlapping things and so
on but but my point is you know you can
resolve that and put it in a cache of
highlight text
you don't have to change it to a new
head that's what you're saying yeah but
then we want something which is called
highlight text I think this goes back to
our original discussion about annotation
like uh strings naked strings they
cannot hold stuff
what images graph audio video they can
have internal options that can hold
annotation
so like the question is do we want an
object that wraps a string and can hold
things for it all right so hold on let's
peel this apart a little bit
so first point is just like we can
annotate audio or images or whatever
else so also we should be able to
annotate text
but the text that we annotate
better be able to be fully styled text
okay not just a string
so my question really here and I can
imagine that the correct design would be
to have a Constructor highlight text
that is the thing that as a low-level
piece of implementation uses annotated
string
along with other things because
highlight text
should
as much be able to you know let's say
I've got a I don't know a piece of an I
don't know what that could be I mean
some some
Well Bar look highlight text
the interface is basically character
based which is okay but there might be
other kinds of highlighted objects but
like highlighting a a grid a table of
some kind where you know in the end some
strings inside it are going to turn into
annotated strings but the big
Constructor is saying to annotate the
whole table
does that make some sense but making it
make sense yeah but this is a bit this I
mean our highlight family graph mesh
image it's the the appropriate type and
Returns the appropriate type
or does it return I mean highlight image
returns an image is that correct uh
right now it Returns the graphics simply
because we cannot uh we cannot
superimpose uh graphical things on image
but we have a plan to add something like
an epilogue option to image so it will
return an image as opposed to it
returning an annotated image yeah
exactly the the only problem is that the
string that doesn't have a head no I
understand that but I'm saying that that
you're saying that image
we're going to stuff the metadata into
the actual image symbolic wrapper yeah
absolutely I think I think that's that's
the that's the that's the goal I mean
the original annotated sorry in the
Highlight image was re-rasterizing stuff
on top and was super ugly it was all
done by pixels so the new version of
course the insane thing to suggest would
be that string
is right now a native type
this is insane I'm not even gonna say
yeah yes we went we went through that
and we marked that as insane when we
discussed annotation so
okay all right but I think I think that
the best way is if you want to I mean I
was asking this with Roger
um he was thinking this might be
something beside annotation
I don't know if you want to call it
string object it seems no I don't know
arrogant out
yeah I think it's it's go ahead it's
high well sorry this is this is a bitter
orthogonal but uh
um have you tried the experiment of uh
highlighting uh a character range that
is part inside of linear syntax in part
outside of linear syntax
no
yeah that's horrifying but it needs to
do something in that something there I
mean I don't even know
how
the um uh let's see
if I were to do
um do you have a prototype build
yes
this this works so important I mean all
these examples that you see in the
Declaration
I see so when you talk about overlapping
the highlights you talk about giving a
list of things where
the character ranges overlap
exactly so right now in the currently
implemented thinking Pros diet pill
there's a check and it stops it if it's
fine that the the two things are are
insisting on the same uh character but I
mean it's an awkward limitation so I
would like to find a way to
to get around that the okay so let's
let's say
um
ah why didn't that go out of the thing
control yeah you you need to write Arrow
it's a bug I've reported it and okay
it's a bug in the Prototype build Okay
so
okay so we got this so now we say text
highlighted text highlight text
our percent one comma Range four five
well there's a spacing there that isn't
right obviously you know that right
well this is one of the question uh that
I have no questions wrong so I mean
there's something to discuss
that spacing is obviously wrong and the
fact that the the thing highlights yeah
you can't have a space an extra space
just because it was highlighted period
end of story
okay then and yeah this was a question
so the the design then is not fine
because we we we we need to have
something which is much narrower around
in general around so like uh what you
have in the ref page so I didn't put the
alternative design here but we have in
ref page is is meant to highlight votes
and he's doing this thing with a rounded
thing because this is what what we have
okay design but okay okay hold on hold
on hold on hold on
if we're doing it character wise not
word wise
okay yes then
I mean this is probably going to need
some logic it's probably going to need
some sort of automated Aesthetics
basically for dealing with the case
um
uh
you know for dealing with this case so
you know it's going to need to actually
look at what's there
you know is it a word does it have space
delimiters
does that make sense yes
in this case it's got to have a narrow
form
so okay
let's deal with a much more horrifying
case
okay let me go
I know where it is 10 14 or something
okay that's pretty horrifying
now try 12 14 which I think will be
inside of the linear syntax is it
well I mean this is already very
horrifying
and and you know given this it's hard to
see how you get out of that box not
wishing to make a pun about boxes
I mean this is based on string take
string group when when you specify the
the character range so I mean what you
say 10 14 was is actually looking at
something like what you have here
no I understand that but I mean the
question really is
this what characters does in this case
oh boy you know I wonder
whether there should be a version of
characters or an option to characters
in which that thing there you know in
the world of emoji
a character
is now much more singing and dancing
quite literally perhaps although there
aren't yet animated Emoji but so what
I'm wondering is
what you mean that what you mean is
grapheme right and we talked about this
that we need an option to characters and
whatnot that returns graphemes rather
than individual characters yes but uh
yeah but how that interacts with linear
syntaxes well I'm suggesting we return
this as a grapheme we've turned this as
a single graphene
somehow we return it as a in characters
we return it as an expression
just as we think about you know an emoji
as a single grapheme that happens to be
representable by a string so this is a
single grapheme that is only
representable by boxes
an interesting characters I mean this
will have to be supported by string
length string take string block string
cases
I mean the truth is as
you know
I would even argue that this is
something that we can have an option to
these functions but honestly anybody
who's been doing character-based stuff
into a box expression is doing something
pretty horrifying and I don't think it
will be horrifying to make the change
now that we have the notion of grappling
for emoji to make the change that just
says this is a single you know grapheme
what does it do remind me what it does
how do I get an emoji tell me how to
give an emoji
by the way
as a question
why don't we have a function called
emoji that just takes as an argument the
um you know smiling cat or something you
know the name of the Emoji
the only reason we don't have that
I thought emojis have like like all
lowercase names and spaces and stuff I
guess we could okay well I mean the
problem is that most emojis don't
actually have names
right really yeah because they're
Composites of other emojis oh I see I
see I see the crazy thing with the
right but I think every Unicode
character has his name doesn't it every
character but most emojis are not but
how do we characters anymore right right
but because it's a whole hieroglyphic
you know language there but I mean it
might be worth having the the general
thing of giving a Unicode character name
display that I mean it'll get the bass
emojis for free and it'll get a bunch of
other stuff too
I think so but I mean don't we have a a
um
I mean we I think it's character name
but that's the name that's from a
character to its name right not from
character name
right
I mean what we have here resource
function
say it again there's a resource function
from character name
does it work for all of Unicode or is it
a curated set
I wrote it a long time ago and I don't
remember what I did to be honest okay
um
okay
that's nice
I mean this is arguably a function we
just really should have because it
reminds me of um
uh you know from
what is it from letter number
which is certainly a useful function
and this is
you know what we should have from
character name
I mean
alternatively
I mean okay we've got from character
code which is just a number based thing
yeah we really should have from
character name along with from character
code
okay so we'll take a look at it and see
if there's any design questions before
we move forward
the main question is where do you look
up the name
right do we look table of hours
right but right do you look up long
names do you look up Unicode names do
you look up
HTML entities I think it probably has to
look up all of them
what if there's a collision
let's find out if there's a collision I
predict there won't be any collisions
presumably you could also take a second
argument I mean well actually what does
letter name do does letter name give you
the option of like give me the HTML name
versus the Unicode name yes it does yeah
what is it your name
okay
character name
right it probably has a second argument
right and you know type in backslash
pipe one f602
all right fine yeah so if you do that
it'll give you Alpha
right okay but if I say HTML as a second
argument
okay
right
okay so this is like I mean to just you
know whatever this you know from
character name should probably just just
be the inverse okay instead of things
right and by default it should I I would
argue that by default it should just use
whatever character name uses its default
right which is yes which is long names
which is fine I mean we except that we
have oops
right so I mean
we need to have something character
entities and um
an interpreter that has names involved
I mean Frank Smiley something that has a
long name
yeah okay fine but I need an actual
foreign type in backslash pipe
uh oh one F6 name just be that 01 you
know backslash pipe oh you know Etc
let's find out I'm in here I've got a
got another idea I've got um
and that's a shame that we didn't make
it available
so
okay that's where's my um
here I can I can put distance yeah I
just put a cuneiform character and chat
if you want to something or like here I
put a plain text that might have a
better chance of getting people oh no it
made it
um
okay so what do I want to do here I want
to say characters
uh
okay so that's because we don't have a
long name for that if you did come you
know comma Unicode or Unicode name I
forget which it is then it'll give you
really
well it's not plain zero Unicode and
maybe we never updated that when we got
Beyond playing zero Unicode according to
my character viewer to q a forms
sign dog kiss me five times God or
something
yeah that's interesting
um well so maybe we just never updated
character name to deal with the uh
Beyond plane zero that's possible yeah
because because right I mean I expect
that answer for the single argument form
but I would have expected Unicode name
to give you you know crying tears of joy
face or whatever is the official Unicode
name for that
wait a code name there actually but
yeah but I think it's probably yeah not
gonna yeah right but so question I mean
Is it feasible to have sort of faux long
names for all of Unicode just by
changing the conventions you know just
by cameling things and so on why not
I mean I don't see yeah but for one
thing at least just my browsing of the
character viewer just now they seem to
be pretty inconsistent but maybe that's
just Apple like the Emojis all have all
lower case names the cuneiform ones
standardize that level
right
um yeah I believe the standard uses all
uppercase but I would have yeah I think
it does I think the standard is you know
it was done at a time when people were
still thinking of cards or something no
it wasn't it was early 90s but they they
chose to not you know mixed case the
names
possibly not a correct decision but you
know that's you know for us this will be
a minor curation to task
but presumably also I mean we could we
could always just show something like
whatever I mean because any of these
things can't you type them as a
backslash bracket
Etc I mean presumably we can just return
that worst case that's numerical it's
purely numerical
attacks but I mean like for example
freaked Smiley isn't that the string you
know
you write backslash bracket for your
smiley sure and character name gives you
just frequency what you're saying you're
saying whatever we
put in whatever we output from character
name so long as backslash bracket that
name Works we're at least somewhere yeah
I agree partly but I think we should
curate the names I don't see any good
reason not to you know Unicode doesn't
come out that often
um it comes out every year okay every
year there's plenty that we curate every
year
what do you think we do with with ticker
symbols for companies and things like
well that that's uh we don't curate that
right we just yes we do so unfortunately
we do unfortunately we we have to deal
with you know this company that is now
you know named you know x dot you know
x-corp or something has ticker this it
changed its name from metacorp to x-corp
or whatever
[Music]
yes we absolutely do have to do that and
we do it
um
okay let's loop back to our original
discussion here
so
okay from character name is it's just a
a thing sorry
two character name
from character name
okay that Nick is going to deal with
exploring that but let's come back to
the Highlight text thing okay so again
I'm making the claim that we should go
to a world in which characters in which
you know I think I think emojis have
delivered a good solution for inline
you know cells and the good solution is
let them be like graphemes
because I think them
you know in fact to me that's a really
good solution
because you know code is going to work
it's clear it's not just a character
it's something more complicated with
these composite emojis it's another more
complicated thing we can kind of build
out these more complicated blobs that
represent graphemes and this is just a
grapheme
okay so I think that's a that's a
separate discussion that we should have
is you know putting options and
characters to return graphemes
Stephen can you try the following do uh
in your end of three put that change to
10 to 9 and the 14 to minus three
I hope that negative numbers work in
highlight text okay so if you enclose
the whole thing it works fine
so yeah yeah I mean why you shouldn't
because it's not breaking the uh exactly
well yes but that this is yeah no yeah I
could have been doing stupid things
you're right yes the truth is we should
change this so that the indexing into
Strings treats this as a graphene
there's let me understand something when
we have a graphene
let's say uh
whatever it is
um
let's say this thing here
the famous
okay so if I say
um
string take oops
if I say string well first of all if I
say characters of this
am I going to get one thing or two
you'll get three
hopefully two God
that is so horrifying us to be
horrifying and I assume string length is
three right
uh yes I hope because otherwise if
length of character isn't the same as
string length that would be very
confusing good okay
you know maybe we should have a world in
which we just say graphemes or whatever
I mean a lot of languages have this now
where they have a distinction between I
mean you know strings are not just lists
of uh characters
well maybe we should look at doing this
because we certainly would know how to
do that for this case
how do we get this as a graph how do we
get a string where it says the person
blah
right could we return that as a list of
graphemes because that's what we kind of
want to do
well right now the the functionality
doesn't exist in the kernel I mean it's
on to the right we discussed this in the
spring and it's on the to-do list to you
know add that capability to characters
okay fine
I forgot we discussed it okay fine
all right
so then
highlight text Will at some point need
to make a decision whether it's whether
it's indexing is graphene based or or
string character based yep
and um although I had I mean
at least until graphing stuff is in I
think it has to be yeah it has to be
string character based yeah right okay
so let's let's look at the horrifying
cases here all right so we've got an
overlap
what is this I don't understand oh this
is just no no ignore I'm generally this
is not supported by the function so I'm
just generally generating mock-ups yeah
okay
so
you know this is
I don't even understand how you would
get to this without an inline cell
of nested
yeah this is a this is a
um how do you say um a framed on top of
the frames okay okay so so what you're
basically saying is if I how do I
generate a piece of random text we don't
have a random text function do we maybe
we should
repository Laura mipsum function I think
okay
well okay so so just yeah we can just do
it
this is also an example data is for
that's a good point too
um
I think the point is you can have an
arbitrary tree of highlights because you
just you if you're just giving
highlighted regions
why does that click to copy do the oh no
that does the right thing sorry
um
okay all right so then here
what we're saying is highlight
text of percent 20 comma span 5 to 10
and also span is a list of lists yes
presumably yes also want span 7 to 14 or
something yeah this right now is gonna I
mean the interface is gonna block this
it's not not supported I think you also
need to miss yeah
yep
so this is just telling you this right
now but uh just because I haven't hooked
it up uh but before before spending too
much time hooking it up uh I I wanted to
run run the design
so there's one other there's an existing
function you know text structure which
also has the same thing of trying to
highlight arbitrary
s on the text yep right but I think it's
pretty different
that is actually doing the thing that is
generating something which is uh is
generating the the roles basically
well like it's generating the input form
of this is a text structure text exactly
it's like uh XML thing
right it's really similar to XML
and by the way it doesn't line break
nicely
I know which we should fix but but this
capability to have a hierarchical
bounding like this is really quite a
nice capability and that's something
that highlight text would be you know it
would be very nice if it did that
right but by the way note that earlier
we're talking about how you you didn't
want the highlighting to add any spacing
but note that this is adding a lot of
spacing
and if you imagine this without the
spacing it's pretty hard to imagine how
you display it
per point
well but but this is a hierarchical okay
first point there's
okay
in terms of something like this
okay look it seems to me that highlight
text is going to need an option that
determines whether it should
hierarchicalize like this
because you might not want it to do that
well I don't know but if you give it if
you give it overlapping regions or
regions that contain each other what's
it going to do if you tell it not to be
hierarchical
well if it isn't captioned it's okay I
mean it just has to change the colors
yeah if you go about right the simple
thing is like the simplest thing we can
do is to do a the same design at what
the Highlight text in the function
repository is doing so just changing the
background of the character that has no
impact on the on the length of the
string the only difference is that I
would do it with the with type setting
instead of by returning a modified
string sure and that that's that's the
basic method that that can handle
character level things very very nicely
it doesn't have problems the decision
here the design decision is what do you
want to do do you want you know use
alpha alpha composing do you want party
transparent colors when you have uh you
know superimposing highlightings but
that's just a graphical thing in terms I
mean the question is whether look
there's going to be an ordering of the
specification of the highlights right so
that there is additional information
Beyond just these are you know it's not
just a set it's an ordering
yeah yeah so you could say that the
second one always
um is override from the first one then
there are several ways it looks like if
if in fact it is
um transparent does it look reasonable
or does it look totally stupid well you
could sum the corners it will you know
you have the the green and red it will
become part of
that's completely ugly probably that's
crazy
where where you pick the colors so that
you know you're nice your black text can
go over them but then the colors mixed
to form you know black or white or
something like that
yeah that's not going to work to do
color Edition like that but maybe
there's a more sophisticated way of
combining colors I mean like what would
we want do we have anybody from graphic
design here what would transparency work
I don't know I mean we can try it here
if you think about a highlighter like on
a piece of paper
yes well I don't know what what you do
when you have a yellow highlighter and a
pink highlighter what do they do when
they mix
and again they they sum with a pigment
room
it depends it really depends on what the
pigments are but yeah
yeah Billy engineering do you have any
comments on this image image multiply
might work
depends on how dark the source colors
are but like with lighter Source colors
multiplies pretty nice
but if you have like five layers of if
you have like a text structure level of
nesting I mean then everything's just
going to be white isn't it
dark it'd be black yeah yeah okay but so
I think what we're going to have to do
is we're going to have to have some kind
of transfer function non-trivial
transfer function that deals with
multiple combining because if it goes to
gray if it kind of you know merges to
gray that's okay if it merges to Black
it's clearly going to kill everything
yeah but also keep in mind that uh you
know citing like focusing at the end
this thing has to work 99 of the time
very well if uh it's all one or less
percent of it and of course you can
create uh uh extreme cases we should get
it right yeah you should get it right I
mean we can get it right I know okay so
you're saying if I say color multiply
what does the image multiply no do image
multiply of image red image something
else that you will see image image
multiply and put inside the first
argument image with like a color inside
like red and second argument image
another corner need to study
so this is what happens
because those are offices
exactly
lighter red and lighter green will do
something
right but but
um
well I mean what is the purpose I mean
it seems like there are a couple
different uses of this function like if
you're just doing very short pieces of
text like you know like was expected
with text structure I think something
like like Julia what you have in this
thing is great where it has you know a
little bit of green bleeding over the
top and stuff like that that's much more
readable than if there were mixing
colors but if you did have like page
pages and pages of text I can imagine
how this would screw up the type setting
things
so I mean
um John fultz is pointing out that grid
actually does do this
look at that
what do you know we already have a model
for this how does that work
that looks like a blend so
effectively opacity
well whatever this is doing seems to me
we can do the same thing because this
has already solved the problem
I don't see any reason to think that
this is not a decent ability no no that
was the first word I said that you can
do some some composition of colors the
the arusu that
mm-hmm
well fine
uh
but I I mean I wouldn't get too dragged
into this because I mean we we have some
core issues to resolve and when those
are resolved we can write that you have
to look at the game anyway in the end we
can have a combiner function as an
option to uh highlight text that could
specify what to do if you've given n
colors you know how you combine them but
in the first approximation it looked
like blend as a reasonable thing to do
and why don't we just do that now I
don't know about the labeling here that
labeling seems crazy weird and um uh you
know I would have thought the labeling I
don't think the labeling should follow
the colors I don't think that's going to
look good most of the time
I guess depends on the color but yeah I
don't think it's going to look good a
yellow label with a yellow color no way
yeah I use a different color function I
mean if you look at the at the ref page
the when you specify a label the color
is is picked by default from the label
so if you have two labels that are the
same you get two highlighting that are
the same
but
um
yeah I mean they can I see so so given a
color of the Highlight there is a label
color that is picked so for
no given a label
given a label the color is picked from
the it's a harsh like color hash
function that uses the label and and so
if you have you know like if you have
the same if your label is uh noun or
Planet two times you get the same
highlighting color no I I understand
that point but I mean
oh I see what you're saying
oh that's interesting okay so you're
saying that
I don't know that's right or not I mean
I can imagine a case where you want to
highlight words and each word needs a
different label but the label has
nothing to do with the
you know the label is merely the label
you know like you might be numbering
words or something one two three
different colors yes for every for every
different number
yeah I mean this can be an option that
can be turned on and off so you can you
can of course manually specify the color
or or you can you can have it this
manual versus automatic is an option
I think if you scroll down there's a
text cases example I mean keep in mind
that the main usage that I had in mind
is NLP and one of the reasons
yeah we have other people
right
okay
well that's amusing I mean that's that's
actually nice I hadn't really
internalized that point that you're
coloring based on a hash so to speak of
the label how weird
it's clever
this is what I use for for highlight
image uh if you if you if you label
regions like for example uh in the for
the the bounding boxes of object
detection you have two cats they get the
same color
that makes sense
it makes sense I hadn't really
internalized it but it makes sense
now out of curiosity does it use random
color or does it does it use color data
to make sure the colors all go together
it uses the the something which is
called the rainbow in color color data
uh no no not rainbows is some some
internal internal uh
by the way I just want to say here as
I've said before I am so fed up with the
fact that the color palettes we have are
never useful to me
and I we should have a little bit of an
analysis of why that is because I just
find that they're not bright enough they
don't communicate range enough et cetera
et cetera et cetera they you know they
they're red at one end
one thing I did once uh when I was
working a lot more on colors was to
um try to recast them uh so that the lab
likeness which is a perceptive thing is
it's scary I know right that makes some
sense Jeremy I mean I know we're working
on the color palette repository but but
we need to have some meeting at some
point to go over why it is you know I've
got use cases for uh you know you've
seen some of those yeah Brett and Tim
know about this and I think that's on
their list but it's I'm not sure where
it's at the I think the repository comes
first and we start filling it with good
you know this would be gradients in that
you're your case right yeah but I mean
well let's okay hopefully we've got a
meeting coming up at the repository soon
um okay let's come back to this design
folk to me these colors look a bit
bright
and you know things like that green
doesn't seem to work very well to me
yeah maybe it doesn't use color for like
you said labels wouldn't probably have
color by default but but hashing them
with the you know the similar color I
like that I I it seems like gray would
be just fine for these labels or dark
gray
fine the text color I mean more like the
uh the translations that we have it kind
of reminds me of that of like function
yes translation textile text element
style is fine or is too bright would you
have in the notebook in the background
that external style what oh
yeah if you scroll up a little bit yes
oh yeah that seems better yeah
and I think these colors are a little
bit vibrant
if you just cut opacity a little bit I
think they'd be okay yeah we can make
with them with opacity they really have
to be light colors because uh oh this is
not a problem I mean text is usually
black on white so you want highlight
highlighting with bright color or a
light color not not to make it super
cumbersome to read what's inside but
this is another thing like what if you
have a sad background but do you care
about this right or no that's exactly
yes I think the answer is yes you care
and that's exactly why I'm saying that
it should interact with Styles and style
text I don't think you can get out of
that box
it's much more than that what if you
have a style sheet in the notebook
I understand I understand so I don't
know I mean that's a question for for
John folks and so on how that should
work but you know that's a reason to
have this thing be somewhat symbolic
until the moment of actual rendering
I don't know how realistic that is oh I
think that if you re-evaluate it in a
different notebook that's the point of
for having something like highlight text
that generates it but the already box
structure if you copy paste to be
dynamic
um
I don't know whether I I don't know
whether that's difficult or not I mean I
don't think John Fox is here so can't
really comment on it I think things like
absolute current value of background is
pretty quick together dynamically it
gets everything all right I didn't know
if it was a thing nice
I I think so I haven't played around
with it in a while but I was doing
something a while back similar to this
and I was getting decent results
okay okay already a front-end command
that I can piggyback without doing
anything in the kernel that's very nice
right that's I think what is being said
so okay so let's come back here to okay
so when they overlap we blend
there's this question about hierarchical
you know things where there's a
appearance you know option of some kind
that hierarchicalizes so that we can get
something that looks like text structure
problems
okay then
there's a question of spacing like if
you do want to adjust the kerning when
you have whole words and not do that
when you have a
um I think the answer is yes I think the
answer is yes and I think it should be
you know I mean this function is more
complicated than one might have expected
but you know that's life that's why it
adds value I mean you know if it was
trivial yeah
um
and that is a thing of the of the output
of the input form of the outcoming what
is the output uh are you happy with the
current thing of these being annotated
the text I'm not sure I'm not sure I
think that there's a certain argument
that it should be
oh
look
I think it is possible that annotated
string
is a good thing to have that can have a
bunch of low-level controls
that are not necessarily conveniently
accessible in all cases by from
highlight text
and for example it's possible that
highlight text
can be more
uh
you know text oriented like text words
and all that kind of thing and more
oriented toward text an annotated string
could contain the low-level stuff that
has the ability to do things that are
more
uh you know I I it bothers me this is
highlight text and yet it doesn't know
the text from a hole in the ground it
just thinks it's a bag of characters
and there's a certain argument that
should be highlight string
if it really is just treating it as a
bag of characters so to speak
yeah I mean text you know there's things
like text words and text cases and so on
which are deeply I mean let's say you
had highlight text and you said Okay I
want to highlight all the quantities in
this text okay that to me is a high
level text operation as opposed to a
low-level string operation which is you
know highlight you know characters 3
through 18 or something
so I mean yeah I might I can make an
argument that both highlight string and
highlight text are possible but
highlight string is what we're currently
designing and it should be a character
oriented thing okay
that makes sense to other people as well
yeah I think I think we have a pretty
clear division between those two areas
of functionality already so it makes
sense to focus on each of them on their
own respective areas
um
okay all right so then is there anything
else go ahead it takes it one last thing
it takes a function also the second
argument that can return like what you
have here where you have a mouse that
can return the expense so you can you
can use the entity functions to to
generate on the slide the the Highlight
to basically Bridge a bit the the thing
you were talking about
well I mean I don't understand this why
is it taking a function there why don't
you just I see that's weird
that this is to avoid the fact that
to repeat the string because because I
could as well get this result by taking
the string call it s and put highlight
text of s comma text cases of s comma
whatever correct
yeah
we also have it in highlight image that
you can pass uh you can pass functions I
mean Health image is more interesting
because it's follow the same syntax
Graphics so you can have an arbitrary
nested thing with the regions n
functions and other things and we'll
resolve basically but uh yeah in this
case maybe is not so important
I'm not sure I think it's kind of a
convenience but it's
oh wow
well look I think this should be
highlight string for now I think the
idea of having annotated string as a
separate low-level construct is
reasonable I don't know what other
people think about that
other comments from people
I think that there's a bunch of
intelligence about the design of these
colors I think we need design
graphic design to opine on what the
color palette should be
then we're going to need some
intelligence about styling and the
interaction between Styles and these
and yeah I mean and then we need this
option for hierarchicalizing the labels
do you see what I'm saying
I think it's a nice function I think
it's going to be really quite useful
function
um
okay let's take a quick look at some
other things on the agenda because then
we're going to have to wrap quickly
um
so
Ian do you want to chime in which of
these three would be the most pressing
to look at are
this is a short one so
we're we're exposing the the internal
option for controlling how many children
to display with this new Max displayed
children option and this is a suggestion
for a dollar Max displayed children
which is a global variable for the
default
but I think a name Max displayed
children disembodied as a you know feels
like you know it's like in times past
when people had 15 children and things
this is the uh as a disembodied name
without Tree in it it seems tough to
have this as a global thing
it seems very weird to just you know you
look through the list of global global
parameters in the system and it's you
know I think it needs
like tree children
well I guess but I mean it doesn't it
seem strange to people to have that
we removed tree from Max displayed like
we suggested Max displayed tree children
for the option and removed tree there
because it's already an option in a tree
function so you don't need to repeat
tree
but we already have a few a few names
that are kind of like you know you're
like what the hell is that yeah well
which one Mexican hat wavelength is a
funny one it says wavelet in its name
though
yeah but it has weather I'm talking
about the dollar things
I mean you know really these are
contexts are understandable in a context
um
natural dollar things are different from
other symbols well no because I mean
they're just like like
okay wait a minute
what was the alternative
go ahead
well no I mean they're definitely
somewhere I'm like I don't know what
that is like dollar template path
yes that's for the template system
right I'm just saying if you're if
you're you know
dollars I thought was going to be 14.3
billion years ago but
it was it was in June
right and frankly and frankly dollar
line on its own is pretty mysterious
yes okay if you don't know okay so it's
I it's I what do you think about this is
dollar Max displayed children okay or
does it need to be contextualized more
in its name
um so I haven't thought about this
um
I think
I think it's probably okay
um but how about panda if it's I thinks
it's okay and nobody else has a violent
objection it's okay I guess
it's a little weird
I mean it would be less weird
it's nice looks nice though
listen redesign that's this next section
here we have Billy and Jeremy for some
design options for religion
okay so so what are we suggesting
there was a
question as to what the text color
should be
for the allotted options there's three
options there's a darker green a gray
which should be probably dark gray and
then a sort of a lighter green below
that one
these all look the same here
let me zoom in
darker green gray that doesn't look
great to me looks dark it's almost yeah
it's almost black
as opposed to what this is that looks
black too this looks the same color the
four and the nine plus 999 plus total
yeah
in in the values they're kind of it's
like a yeah it's it's they're about
they're the same
okay good here look at this this looks
lovely here except I think the dashing
should be more you know fine-grained
I think the dashing is too coarse but
otherwise I like this
and by the way never do that of saying
999 plus
never just give the number
the number will never be that big it
doesn't fit in computer memory
see what I'm saying
okay
um
so I don't understand I mean
I don't know what other people think but
I'm I'm okay with this green color I
think it looks pretty reasonable as a
kind of an extra and it's kind of green
on green and it seems reasonable to me
okay I'm confused what are we what are
we talking about here this this seems
fine to me except that the dotted line
should be less coarse who is objecting
to this is anybody what where do we get
you wanted another pass to be done over
what is on the right
okay well so but I want to know what why
do we think what do design folks think
is wrong with what's on the right and
explain why
there are options to choose from okay
but I don't think these are but there's
no concept for why these would be better
I mean to me this looks about right
because we want this this thing here and
again I need to see something with less
coarseness in the dotting when you
scroll down in the notebook there's a
bunch of yeah this stuff
that was one of the the improvements and
there's some other options
scroll down until you see like a
reference material
and then there's dashing
well I mean
yeah that's the one we picked yeah well
that's good yeah
you like tiny tiny
yeah that's that's what it is
you need to check it works when you
magnify the cell and stuff like this
okay but it doesn't go crazy when you
magnify the cell
but I don't know what these other things
are I I think what really is this issue
here
um what what should the United nodes do
when you set the base Style
scroll up
right should they inherit or be
interaction or you can't change
like should they always say this green
I don't understand this why didn't this
go tree element Style
I don't understand why this didn't
affect all the nodes here
the tree elements Arrow style if you
want it to be all
you just give a style it's just that
node except right now there's kind of a
hack that the alighted node uses the
same style as the parent
well that's clearly not gonna work
well maybe what you need is a name for
the alighted node in your list of you
know maybe you need some some
perhaps string name or some other name
in the list of things where you say this
node you know where you're saying all
gets blah blah blah right the question
is does all
mean all or does the alignment all
affect the alighted node and also would
base style affect the lighted node well
you know maybe full can affect the
alighted node and all cannot affect
might not affect the alighted node
I think the default should be to not
affect the lighted node
I think the Allied node is kind of
metadata that is separated from oh I
want to color this this way I think
that's what we thought too well so then
maybe full can be an option setting that
is you know beyond all that will affect
the allotted nodes
does that make sense Ian yep
and then in terms of how to affect just
the alighted nodes
I would have said we need some name I
don't know I'm not happy with Stringer
lighted or something but some some name
or some mechanism
um
or some uh you know some name like all
except not all like inherited or
something supporting weaves and
non-leaves so maybe there could be
another string name yes that would be
good yes that would be good so leaves
non-leaves you know alighted nodes or
something the lighted leaves whatever a
lighted yeah whatever whatever you want
to call it the light it leaves alighted
subtrees
a lighted sub trees sounds better to me
because they are sub trees in general
um I think that's a good solution what's
that
I like a lighted subtrees I think that's
a good solution to you know you can you
can color the node you can color the
leaves you can color the
whatever
um
all right that seems reasonable to me I
I need to run along here
um
and uh
okay we'll pick up the remaining items
next time around then right sounds good
and Jeremy I think you're needed in the
thing that we're doing right in the next
five minutes okay yep
um
okay uh thanks a lot guys all sorts of
interesting stuff see you later